Google cloud next 2017 has hosted a
plethora of talks detailing the future
of cloud if you didn't get a chance to
check out meteo at Mel's talk running
net on Google cloud then stay tuned
because here's the recap historically
dotnet and Google cloud platform haven't
exactly played well together the reasons
for this are complex but one of the
biggest challenges has been around the
language and tooling not working very
well with scalable Linux VMs but brace
yourselves that's no longer the case
improved Linux support for the dotnet
environment has allowed the framework to
extend its reach and the availability of
Windows VMs on Google compute engine
opens doors for new types of
applications to run on Google
infrastructure see the decision to run
net on GCP is no longer an issue of
features and supports it's about
choosing the best cloud platform for
your needs and when it comes to dotnet
development GCP has some new features to
help you be more productive let's start
by looking at the libraries and tools
we've provided a suite of runtime
libraries that make it easy for your
application to interface with the full
suite of GCP services that includes
everything from the vision API and
natural speech API authentication and
data store all available for your dotnet
app we're also providing visual studio
plugins and powershell commandlets to
help you manage your DCP resources from
within the tools you're already using on
a day to day basis on the compute side
of things we've got support to boot a VM
with Windows on it but we also go
further by offering Google cloud
launcher which gives you one-click
deployment to Windows servers that come
pre-installed with things like asp.net
and the Google cloud platform dotnet
libraries but if you've already done
that legwork yourself and are running
say a container with Windows and asp.net
core on it don't fret you can deploy
that with ease using App Engine flex
environment or our kubernetes platform
Google container engine and the best
part is that all of this is running on
Google's infrastructure which already
offers fast vm provisioning simple auto
scaling and per minute billing
not to mention access to manage services
like a BigTable datastore dataflow cloud
storage and genomics processing
GCP also provides the Federation of
tools and services which make your
deployments production-ready the health
check system can monitor your instances
and a fully expanded and accessible
orphaned IM system allows you to control
who and what has access to everything
plus there's integration to stackdriver
which gives you logging reporting
tracing and monitoring of your cloud
service right out of the box
check out the recording of met a full
session to see a bunch of cool demos of
asp.net running on google cloud and if
you want more recaps on great next
content make sure to check out the rest
of the playlist and don't forget the
next world tour which is coming soon to
a city near you
[Music]